[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les relations entre la corée du nord et
les états unis
c'est une relation qui est très tendue
entre le président tromper son homologue
nord coréen cha homme qui à de
nombreuses reprises à insulter le leader
nord-coréen qui tient absolument à
développer son arsenal nucléaire
monsieur trump qui n'a pas exclu
d'attaquer même à parler d'anéantir
carrément la corée du nord mais il ya
des négociations qui s'ouvrent peut-être
entre la corée du nord et la corée du
sud pour une participation aux jeux
olympiques
est ce que c'est la brèche qui s'ouvre
la possibilité de démarrer une solution
diplomatique à ce conflit est ce que
monsieur thiam prendra la balle au bond
et favorisera davantage une solution
diplomatique au lieu d'une solution
militaire
chose certaine les yeux seront rivés
vers washington et pyongyang
[Musique]
l'enquète du procureur spécial robert
morin sur la possible collusion entre
l'entourage de campagne présidentielle
dans notre job et les russes poursuit
aux états unis on ne sait pas trop où
exactement où cette enquête va mener la
présidence trombe ce que l'on sait c'est
que le travail de leur bus man 2 est
très méthodique et plusieurs personnes
déjà dans l'entourage du président qui
ont été accusés on parle maintenant de
possibles accusations à l'endroit de son
fils peut-être même de son gendre
alors cette enquête du procureur spécial
demeure une épine au pied parce qu'elle
a un bête dans notre chambre et dans
notre chambre qui n'a pas non plus exclu
la possibilité de faire démissionner de
congédier le rythme heureux et de mettre
fin à cette enquête qui empoisonnent sa
présidence
[Musique]
les élections de mi mandat aux états
unis seront probablement l'événement
politique majeure à suivre en 2018 tout
d'abord ce sera l'occasion pour les
démocrates de démontrer qu'ils sont
encore capables d'occuper le pouvoir et
de reprendre le contrôle non seulement
de la chambre des représentants mais
également du sénat il ya de nombreux
démocrates qui veulent entamer une
procédure de destitution contre le
président tiab
il leur faut absolument une majorité à
la chambre pour entamer cette procédure
alors des élections de mi-mandat
extrêmement importantes aux états unis
que l'on va suivre pour vous